let's jump to the story this is huge
news from timcast.com scotus strikes
down new york state's proper cause gun
control law
justice thomas says second and 14th
second and 14th amendments protect an
individual's right to carry a handgun
for self-defense outside the home that's
an amazing statement yes and
the reason i uh um i wanted to jump into
the story too is we're getting into the
gun control conversation
one of the statements made by alito was
that
the the the uh argument from the gun
control side
was that these laws are needed to
prevent mass shootings and he said
one of those happened in new york where
you have this law it did not do anything
that's the most frustrating thing to me
is that you get a lot of these uh uh
these gun control people argue for
things that already exist i had someone
just sent to me an article and it was
like these laws could could end gun
violence and it was like
four things that are already in place
banning assault rifles is like
that or did you google this before you
write wrote it or shared it right one
that was the reason i even asked the
congressman is because
you're literally seeing people on the
left just accuse if you're not pro gun
control that you just are cool with
murder instead of asking people with
experience with firearms hey what do you
as someone who has more experience than
me who's never touched a gun what do you
actually think we should do yeah i i
tell you what i the laws are there the
laws are on the books they just need to
be enforced you know in texas now we
have a constitutional carry so you don't
have to go out and get an ltc you don't
have to go out get a license it's a
constitutional carry so people are
carrying guns and i tell you what the
crime in in houston is out of control
and people are starting to carry more
guns you're seeing up you know sales
increasing guns because if people can't
count on their government to keep them
safe george soros has is gone out there
and all these da's are in these offices
now across our country and they're
leaving these criminals out so these
people i think the american people are
starting to carry more weapons because
they say i can't count on my government
to keep me safe i have to keep myself
safe in my family and i can't blame them
because it's out of control our cities
are burning gentlemen now is that is
that working are the are the places with
more people carrying do they become
safer because of that sort of fear
tactic of i'll tell you this when i
started when i finally moved to southern
states i certainly don't honk my horn as
much when i'm cut off because i'm like i
don't know what that guy's carrying i
understand and that's not the point it's
better to have it not need it need it
not have it but i'm just saying that
criminals would have to kind of pause a
little bit and take a second thing hey
am i going to pull a gun on that guy
because he may have one so let's talk a
bit about this uh this this ruling
uh we can thank brett kavanaugh for
not
for blocking constitutional carry
nationwide shocking he said basically
that this does not impact the existing
permitting rules in 43 states that means
if you're in a state that requires a
permit for concealed carry well they did
not touch that come on kavanaugh you
should have come out and been like the
government that the government requiring
permission for you to bear arms is an
infringement upon your right to bear
arms
however he's of the opinion the
government can not stop you from having
it but they can be forced to grant
permission which in my opinion makes no
sense because if they can deny you a
permit for any reason then government
permission as a requirement infringes
upon your rights but this does mean that
it's likely going to impact maryland new
jersey it's going to obviously it's new
york california hawaii and the district
of columbia so this means in all
likelihood these states will now have to
actually give you a permit it's already
prohibitively
re it's restrictive in terms of what you
need to do to apply for one so while
this is a good ruling the problem is
maryland is not going so here's how it
works maryland new york new jersey they
say okay you felt the forms you got the
training
why do you need the weapon
and this is what the supreme court
struck down you can't ask that you can
tell them here's the requirements and
then you got to give them the permit
because these states were just saying
why you need a legitimate reason for
this and no matter what you said they
went nope one of the plaintiffs said
he needed a weapon because of a string
of violent robberies in his area and
needed to protect himself and they said
no
i'm like what more could you ask for if
you're famous if you're rich some of
these states will give them to you but
new jersey new york still don't even if
you're rich and famous i got rejected
and i just said revenge
yeah it's not that's not a good reason
not a good one
i once saw a guy in walmart trying to
buy a gun and he was openly talking
about how he wanted to get revenge on
someone no really yeah and then he got
escorted out by the police they wouldn't
sell to him that's good but uh so so
basically what's happening now is the
next moves in my opinion it's a good
victory it's tremendous but what's
likely going to happen is that new
jersey and new york will just create
very restrictive permitting practices
that's what that's what they were doing
and then they're going to say
we can't ask you for why you need it but
we can ask you to undergo a three-month
psychiatric evaluation so once again
they jam you up then someone's gonna
have to sue and this took seven years to
get through seven years
yeah you know i've made it very clear
that i will not be supporting this
legislation coming through the senate
and it's just it's very difficult uh
you think that all the laws that are out
there if you think creating more laws
are going to keep the criminals from
carrying weapons they don't care they
don't care about your supreme court they
don't care about the chief of police or
any laws they're going to continue to
carry these weapons they're going to
continue to to to heart and harm the
american people the the people that are
out there doing good things the
criminals have the guns and they're not
giving them up now now hold on you were
a sheriff for 30 years or you're in love
as share for eighteen law enforcement
30. law enforcement 30's so this is in
texas i imagine right that's right so uh
you mean to tell me that you know so one
constitutional carry is relatively new
but you actually encountered people who
defied the law and carried weapons
imagine that but that doesn't make sense
wait wait i thought this can't be true
it was illegal it was like little johnny
little johnny do you know you're a
convicted felon yes sir do you know you
can't carry a gun yes sir
yeah did they read the signs they do not
they decide
i'm not following the little johnny
doesn't care
little johnny doesn't care and and
you're wondering we had shootings here
in washington dc here last week and it
was a 15 year old and he had a gun and
then there was one a couple weeks prior
to that he was 15 year old had a
girlfriend 15 years old girlfriend eight
months pregnant he had a gun and i'm
thinking to myself you want to talk
about the breakdown of the family right
the the the fatherless
there's no fathers in their lives and
and it's just causing problems so
that's what it is
a major issue with shootings is that
people don't have debts and the problem
is when you try and bring that up to the
left they they don't understand i
shouldn't say the left i always do that
leftists they actually like guns it's
liberals it's these urban liberal types
they they can't think beyond
single-layer issues
they think someone got shot therefore
get the gun away and it's like but you
need to understand the person who had
the gun had it illegally already your
new laws won't change so in chicago for
instance they're like
well it's not chicago's fault they're
doing the shootings they're getting the
guns from indiana and it's like
what more law could you put in illinois
if you've already got them don't you get
it you will ban all the guns everywhere
they say they don't want to ban guns but
then that's the only argument we'll
destroy indiana well did you see the
story yesterday another big beautiful
wall did you see the store yesterday uh
a guy walks into a one of the stores
with a gun to rob the store and the
clerk the clerk had a gun and shot and
killed him and the siblings of the
robber they were outraged on the news
they're actually on the news the sister
was saying this is ridiculous i know he
went in and robbed him but he shouldn't
have been shot he was pointing a gun at
the clerk the clerk had a gun and shot
and killed this guy so this is the type
of uh
yeah i saw a similar story years ago um
i just want to make one point really
quickly about this this is one of the
really interesting and obvious flaws
with the left is
they want to be really really really
harsh on potential crime which is to say
going after people who haven't done
anything wrong because there's a
potential that they might and then when
someone actually commits a crime they
want to be really lenient about it
there do you see the the story of the
woman in the cell phone store and the
guy walks in and and she goes hi can i
help he goes yeah do you have a boom and
just starts
mercilessly beating her for no reason
yeah and these are the people they will
say these are the people who they will
say uh you know should be able to walk
without bail and you know it's so cruel
that the criminal justice system doesn't
give them a second shot but then when it
comes to law-abiding citizens they talk
about restricting our freedom so that
crime won't occur it's so backwards
remember kamala set up an account that's
right for the 2020 riots to bail out
those individuals and that was a true
insurrectionist listen when you go up to
seattle and you occupy city blocks what
was it the chairs and shopping
that is an insurrection fellas without
question they were burning down
buildings a police station everything
else and look at many of them it was
mostly peaceful fire minnesota
that's what they were dead
but mostly peaceful there were
marshmallows burning behind you exactly
exactly so i i i'm sorry
this is why
there i think there is a the political
factions are the cult and regular people
because
you have people who are like the riots
that burn down police stations were
peaceful they they outright say it they
write uh articles saying in defense of
looting after the ferguson writes they
were like actually looting is is
revolutionary and they're defying the
system and i'm just like you know did
you talk to any people who lived in
ferguson because they were angry about
the riding begging for it to stop and
then these progressive urban liberal
types city urban liberal types come out
write articles being like actually the
writing is good because they're they're
vapid self-interested egotists
who don't understand what's actually
going on i'll tell you in ferguson
people who did not live there exploited
the chaos and started destroying things
and looting them and the people who did
live there were linking arms saying
please this is our community these
snooty progressive hipster types in new
york not wanting to do any amount of
work to understand the situation looked
at it and said i'm going to defend those
brown people because there must be a
good reason why they're rioting and then
wrote in defense of looting
ins and what it really was was criminals
victimizing a community and they
defended the criminals because they're
bad people well and i also i mean i will
never forget footage what happened to
george floyd was horrific i remember
seeing footage of
during the rioting um
two black women
begging
begging a white person to stop
destroying property yeah and it's like
hey these are the ones who
when you taurus when you hipster taurus
go back to your co-op and park slope and
all that stuff they're the ones who
still have to live here it's their
stores you're not they're not the ones
who killed george floyd they're not the
ones you know but look look when
you simply say something like i think
when they burn down that guy's bar it
was a bad thing and they go well you're
racist it's like okay dude yeah well
there's no argument they don't know how
to think outside that so we also see
this there is obviously
a huge part that class plays here so we
were talking about this with the
canadian truckers honking their horns
and literally one of the wealthiest
neighborhoods in the country all right
honking your horn in such a neighborhood
is terrorism you're trying to overthrow
the country but you go into a poor black
neighborhood and burn all the businesses
down that's just a-okay right and
justify means you'll scare all the moose
if you honk in canada thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm we'll see
you all there